[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett it's time for another conversation
with somebody interesting from the
internet and this week that person is 23
year old King Russell and that's not a
king who is Russell that's his actual
name but you know him on YouTube and
elsewhere as Kingsley he's amassed over
2.8 million subscribers on YouTube just
under four years and he's most popular
for these vlogs that he does vlog series
called overexposed basically he rants
about things various pop culture things
and also stuff to the experiences in his
daily life and it's very funny I mean
he's a legitimately funny dude when I'm
watching his videos I'm just waiting for
the next thing he's gonna say that's
funny and every other thing he says is
funny and very much Kingsley I love how
this space allows comedians to develop
in all different types of ways and he
certainly developed his own comedic
voice he's got a tone yeah it's very
good you know I think on this ear
biscuit we got more of the pensive side
of King we got he did not reign
perspective I will say that he did not
rent at all but that's not really what
your biscuits is about it's not about
your rants it's kind of just about you
talking about yourself and getting more
than the real side of him so I
appreciated that but just so you can get
a taste of what the Internet has come to
know and love about Kingsley here's an
example of a rant in June 2010 he
released things I hate about driving you
know when you get off like a street and
you're going into the highway and this
lanes gonna end that you just got off on
they will literally go all the way to
the end and then want to sit up here and
try to get impatient when they want to
wait to the last minute to try to get
over into everybody's lane you had a
straight mile to get you over into the
main lane okay that one's got over three
million views to date
here's another rant where he's talking
about Rebecca black March 2011 has just
under nine million views it is the most
annoying song slash video I heard slash
teen
my 20 years of existing on this planet
it starts out and there's like this
calendar and it keeps flipping through
the days of the week while a cartoon
version of her annoying bass I send up
there singing with her little harmonies
like test on Monday to sing at this
recital blah and then Friday gets here
and wrote all over the page finally
hooray eub she's like I gotta get up
gotta get fresh gotta go downstairs get
a bowl have my stereo
Kingsley's one of the only openly gay
black mail online personalities it's
near the top of the charts on YouTube
and he's been at it for a number of
years the momentum is still growing he's
actually just started his own podcast
called Kingsley overexposed and we're
happy to have him on our podcast which
was almost called underexposed
last-minute change became ear biscuits
so that would have worked out really
well on this this week so we talked to
King about how he received his first
break courtesy of Tosh Tosh point OH his
last name was not point Oh like King is
not an actual King right even though
maybe they both should look into those
things right we talked to King about how
even though he uses a lot of profanity
in his vlogs
he never cusses in front of his parents
and we also explored the question
surrounding is he actually quitting
YouTube at the end of 2014
why is it it's been a topic of
discussion amongst his fans viewers and
himself we get to the bottom of that
much more in this year biscuit let's do
it
[Music]
in a recent blog you said that you went
to the Billboard Music Awards and you
walked the red carpet and you said that
once they started snapping pictures of
you you kind of were like what was going
through your mind you tell us again I
don't know I was just looking like first
there's like there's a process they have
us all line up and then we just go to
the carpet one by one and then they
called my name and I just like went in
front of the little poster thing or
backdrop or whatever it's called and
then the photographer's just start
screaming they just start screaming your
name look over here look over here do
this do that and I'd never done a red
carpet before so I was just sitting up
there like what the hell is going on
like what am I supposed to do I didn't
know where to put my hands I didn't know
who to smile at and then like I just
don't know how to pose it was completely
out of my element and I was just like
wanting it to be over you know when you
like smile for a really long time and
you kind of start like it kind of gives
out a little bit yeah and you start like
twitching yeah have you googled Kingsley
Billboard Music Awards because we did oh
great well there's a number of pictures
and we learned this a couple years ago I
learned that you know after you go to an
event like that and they take your
picture on the red carpet the next
couple of like that next week all these
pictures just pop up and all these
different photo sites right right and
your picture you see well you have a
number of pictures but the full-body one
wouldn't oh my god I'll show it to you
it's a okay there's a lot of your face
but then the full-body one kind of like
oh my god there's lots of great pictures
this one though when I saw it when I
heard your story in your vlog and then I
saw this picture discloses this is
incredible describe yourself basically
I'm looking at I look bewildered or like
that's a good horse pissed off at
something I'm like them at the camera
like yes it's great in your hand yeah
and there's a wider shot of it and your
arms are just both like oh my god at
your sides
the last time I don't know what event it
was but we walk the red carpet we always
walk it together right so it's you feel
a little bit more comfortable when
you've got somebody to pose with right
but I just remember but you feel a
little funny when they're like okay
what's your name blink you first it's
like no no no no we say with me we do it
together but do you remember the last
time I did this you're too afraid to go
by yourself
this guy said we were doing our pose we
I mean we've got just a couple of poses
right yeah and basically one face
because I'm like I want this picture to
be consistent throughout the Internet
the guy said do something different one
of the photographers actually said that
he's like can you do something different
I was like nope because he wanted he
wanted that one picture that like
Kingsley could pull up on his podcast
when we come on there that you can maybe
make fun of us but I mean in fairness
you were making fun yourself we just
googled it to see if you if it was real
and we found out yeah it's real I mean
your vlogs are inspired by your your
your experiences in your your life
you're not making this stuff up and you
know we just had to make sure that and
in this case it was totally true totally
- you didn't know what to do I just like
dead away well let's uh let's go back
were you from I'm from well I was born
in Arkansas born Aniyah and so I moved
to Missouri when I was six and then I
was there ever since until about two and
a half years ago when I moved - okay so
your earliest memories are Arkansas
memories what are those like oh my
goodness those are very they're like
they're not really there but they're
there it's funny because I was looking
at where I grew up on Google Earth like
two weeks ago Google Arkansas yeah and
it was just like dirt like an end of
residential space but it was I don't
know Arkansas was very rural small town
I think there were like less than a
thousand people in the town where I grew
up mm-hm
we had like one elementary school um -
gas station
a post office and then like houses and
like a railroad track went through the
town and everyone had to work and like
the nearest city which was like 12 miles
away so nobody nobody worked in this
little town no unless you're at the gas
station or post-office
Alzheimer Arkansas it's like I thought
all time love and Little Rock yeah
that's like the incorrect way to say all
time that's your town I know sometimes I
want to say Alzheimer's but I can't but
yeah if you don't know how to pronounce
a really horrible disease that's where I
live I mean that's I mean that's
incentive to move right there
mm-hmm I miss it though oh yeah well
you're looking at a non piccolo have you
been back I haven't been back since the
last time I went was before I moved here
I went to see my sister and also you
still got family in this small town I do
well my sister's in the city that's like
12 miles outside of it but I have aunts
and my grandma was in the small town but
she moves like a few months ago okay
yeah it's very like becoming like
dilapidated and like I'd go me it goes
down yeah it's actually kind of scary
what do you call your grandma and what
does she think of your videos I call her
granny actually because I have her and
then I have another grandma on my mom's
partner side and I call her grandma and
then call my grandma my mom's grandma
granny and she hasn't seen my videos so
he hasn't no I don't think so I hope not
really so what's the conversation like
when you talk to granny it's just at
this point she's kind of older so it's
just like how are you doing I miss you
come visit she doesn't ask what you do
or anything sometimes she doesn't even
it's kind of sad like she doesn't
realized I'm not at home oh I'm gonna
talk to her on the phone sometime like I
don't think she realize I'm in
California okay yeah I got into a
situation the same thing for your
grandma she doesn't know what she did
he's she's still kicking she's like an
active ass grandma she does like running
and she's still in like choir and she
powerwall it's like every day she cooks
she's like superwoman does she watch
your videos no but she knows about them
and like all my family
but but I mean but she knows what you do
yes she understands why you're out here
why don't you like when you family tell
me more about that
what is this mainly the profanity
because when I'm around my family I'm
just okay different person and a respect
for like adults I just don't use
profanity and one of the things when my
mom first realized what I was doing um
one of my aunts I think had stumbled
upon me I think after the whole tosh
point-o thing that I was on and my mom
called me briefly what was the tosh
point-o thing I did this video about
like a list of pet peeves that I had and
I was literally just sitting on my dorm
room just talking about how I hated like
skinny jeans and couples that sit on the
same size of the booth like literally
just a list of stupid things but you
were you were being you were in Kingsley
yeah its Kingsley [ __ ] mode it was like
spring break and I still had to work and
like nobody was on campus and I was just
bored out of my mind but but your
language was much more colorful than
what you would use with your yeah way
more culpable I never use profanity I
said one time in front my mom when I was
in the car I was like it's hot like I
didn't it doesn't rolled out and I like
gripped the side of like the passenger
door and I looked at her with my eyes
like so wide I was like I'm so sorry
like I just that's not how I grew up I
don't know how I became she's mad or
something
no she just started laughing she's like
it's okay that was literally deep first
and only time I've ever used I don't
really want my parents like really it's
not how I grew up I never but when you
when you first started like that first
rant video that got really popular they
had the colorful language was that were
you did you have that language in your
your normal life it was like I'm going
into a character here that I know will
be funny it was like my first rant that
I uploaded it was authentic I was
genuinely like perturbed about it was
about like this experience I had at um a
parking lot of an Applebee's with the
Jonas Brothers who had a concert that
summer and like
they're fans I completely took over the
parking lot like beyond the arena and it
was just a mess and I was trying to get
food and they were everywhere with their
posters and like playing music and just
you know how girls are when there's like
a guy band and they're just completely
over-the-top rabid yeah and I went home
and I had been watching YouTube that
summer um I think I started watching
Shane Dawson what's the first person I
started watching and through him I just
found other people and I suggest saw
them talking and I was like oh my god I
want to make a video about this and so I
did it and um people responded to it and
then that's like when I kind of molded
the character like this outlandish
profane careless being but the for that
first that first video was just going on
anger and adrenaline and frustration
yeah and so this language that you were
never allowed to say was coming out and
I felt good okay did your so tell me
more about your parents back then and
kind of growing up well I mean does that
mean that they were really strict or
really heavy-handed they weren't strict
like okay my parents are lesbians my mom
and her partner and I just never like I
guess it's strict like I couldn't watch
TV a lot like I watched two hours of TV
a day that was my limit and I had like
an hour to half limit for the internet
and um all the movie channels were
blocked anything above like pg-13 was
blocked like I was very I guess
sheltered in a way was it like a
religious home too or no it was just
they wanted me to be a kid I guess I
have no idea like what their intentions
were but I just I didn't have a lot of
exposure to like profane or crazy things
well and let's back up a second because
you say your parents are lesbians I
assume a man was involved at some point
in the process so how did how did that
happen um I'd still to this day don't
really know the full story but I know
that my dad left my mom when she was
pregnant with me and so with her it was
like
situation of just being an Arkansas and
it was very close behind it down there
he's like she wanted kids like my
sister's older than me so she'd had my
sister already and like she was doing
what she needed to do to like survive I
guess um not be judged she was just
doing the whole southern with a man
having kids thing and then I think that
she met her partner when I was I want to
say three ish and they've been together
ever since
and we moved like I said when I was six
we all moved to st. Louis and that was
just life as I knew it but you didn't I
think in one of your videos you you you
mentioned that you're your parents your
mom and her partner we're together
mm-hmm but you didn't you just thought
they were friends there was like this
yeah it was a point right if your mom
wasn't out to you right when I was
younger I told me when I was very young
but I didn't care like she literally one
day came in my room and sat on the phone
and she's like we are what society would
call lesbians I don't know what the hell
she was talking about was like okay but
like it was a situation where like you
got someone's like dating someone a
woman dating a man and like if she has a
kid should be like this is uncle Steve
yeah it's really not uncle Steve like I
think from what I remember she told me
that that was my aunt and so I thought
they were just like living together but
again I was so young I didn't care I
didn't really know what was going on
right but more in a protective way of I
don't want to tell Kingsley that I'm
dating this person that could be another
mom to me or whatever and then we break
up and then you know I guess I take it -
that's what you mean there was like a
protection on that level yeah it was
entirely I didn't want to protect him
from understand that I'm dating a woman
where and I think of the situation where
she wanted me to know when she felt I
was ready to wear maybe like I didn't
get made fun of or something I don't
know what she was thinking but either
way I didn't care so what was that part
of the move to st. Louis was that one of
the things that motivated it was you
know being a small town in Arkansas as a
lesbian couple for sure I think that and
then just career
for us in the Midwest like st. Louis is
like a big city so it's like a super big
deal to move from where we were to
Missouri and um it was just great it was
like I feel like a chance for them to
start fresh and then my sister to start
fresh because we moves like right before
I started kindergarten or anything so
it's just a completely new start and was
it like a mind-blowing announcement when
like she went from being what's her name
and what do you call her like you call
her mom too or oh no I don't call her by
her first name
okay yeah I call my mom mom but I still
like my mom I just don't write a mom
yeah but what was it like a mind-blowing
announcement oh now my my my mom's
friend is now my mom's spouse or a
partner no I really when she told me I
didn't comprehend anything I don't think
you're still young then yeah I don't
think until I guess like middle school
high schools I start to realize like
what a lesbian was okay and like what my
parents were and um how did that relate
to you understanding of yourself as
being gay did you your mom was always
out to you were you always out to
yourself to know me like being gay was
so weird like I feel like I knew I
obviously knew but I never mentioned it
to anyone I don't even mention it to my
parents um the first time we even
remotely talked about a guy I was
working at Fridays and it was my senior
year of high school and this kid from
Detroit was like there was like five of
his friends and he gave me his phone
number and um I was working at the host
and he was just flirting and I just felt
like really really like I don't know how
I thought I was just feeling some type
of way that I felt before in my life and
like I'm good yeah okay my mom picked me
up
and I just told her about it like oh my
god this guy came in and he was really
cute and blah blah like that was that
like I never thought twice about it it
wasn't a big deal and then until I was
in college which was like maybe like a
year after this she called me up and she
literally just said to me say it like
say what she's like that you're gay and
I started laughing for like five minutes
then I eventually said it and I thought
was that so that they knew I just
never situation where I felt the need to
like announce it mm-hm and when did you
know I feel like I knew in like eighth
or ninth grade I feel like that's when
I'm trying to remember who it was but I
remember like having my first crush on a
guy in middle school so I want to say
like eighth grade yeah okay and that was
it that was in st. Louis so you know you
moved to st. Louis right before starting
school basically and what was that like
new kid at first like I don't remember
it like distinctly but I know I was
excited like I wasn't sad or anything um
I was always like adventurous I remember
just being on planes like I loved flying
I love traveling and it was only six
hours away so like when we first moved
we visited a lot um but I just I don't
know I wasn't a shy kid like I was just
ready for the world and I went to school
I always loved school and I just thought
st. Louis was like a cool place
I immediately got involved in a bunch of
stuff and it was a pretty good
experience and what were you what were
you into at that time we use like I know
you I know from your vlogs and that you
were a smart kid
yeah immediately immediately they
recognized okay this kid is gifted and
put him in some advanced classes and
that kind of thing I started out and my
first passion I guess was choir um I
sang from I sing in church when I was
like four or five and then when I
started school in st. Louis I joined
choir in first grade
um I got into Orchestra I played the
violin yes I did and then I heard I was
a little little gay nerd and then I
played the saxophone and band once I got
to fifth grade but only did that for
like two years so yeah and then I was
involved in theater and scholar bowl
Spelling Bee II just any I was very
immersed in school because I didn't get
to do much outside of school not that I
need to as a child but like I just liked
doing things I liked staying after
school I liked meeting different people
in different activities and just like
being involved and you know
teachers from a very young age I just
liked networking but if you weren't out
to your mom until college then I guess
you weren't out to your friends either
so that was kind of like it was I didn't
say it but they knew like even with some
of my friends in high school like I
would talk about guys
I just wasn't ever once people that was
like I'm gay and I didn't like I wasn't
part of like the Gay Straight Alliance I
didn't do anything proactive I guess
that I could have to been more part of
the community I just was it wasn't part
of your public identity yeah I wasn't I
don't know if I wasn't comfortable with
it but I just the way that school was it
I just never felt the need to like make
it a big deal but you made a big deal
out of Britney Spears yes instead I
think that was a dead go away right so
tell me about that the Britney obsession
you know it's actually my mom's fault I
was in my room when they been doing
homework and I just heard this like I
heard like and I'm like what what are
you watching listening to and I like
peeked my head around the corner and she
was watching like music videos and toxic
was on and I was just fascinated and I
was like oh my god oh my god and then
back then like there was some like vivo
or anything and so I would literally
like watch the TV channel the MTV had
that showed like music videos 24 hours
trying to catch that video like any
chance that I got and I finally saw it
and I was just ever since then I was
just fascinated and what I'm what
specifically I mean what is obviously
there are other female pop stars what
what is it about Britney well initially
it was just that specific song and that
video and how she looked and I ended up
going back and listening to like her old
stuff because that's like a black person
like Britney wasn't like I knew who she
was but in my house she wasn't like a
fixture yes obviously she was like to
the world at that time and then I just I
don't know it just fell in love with her
music and then I would see her perform
and then the whole crap happened why she
like lost her mind in her lair made me
like her
at her hair and isn't me like even more
because I felt like she was someone
relatable who like got super famous and
couldn't handle the pressure and just
cracked and then you did a presentation
on her at some point I did I did a
presentation and disliked graphics media
class or something we had to do a
PowerPoint unlike a person that was
important to our lives like a celebrity
not go anyone and so I kept her and it
was a disaster okay tell us about that
those I was in the class I was there was
me I think there was like actually I
don't think there were any girls in that
class except for the teacher and um I
don't like all the guys picked like
athletes or like rappers or I don't even
know and then I was my turn what was it
what's the demographic breakdown of your
school at of this class I mean is this a
public school yeah it's a public school
um I'd say mostly white and black
students some guy um there weren't a lot
of like there wasn't much besides that
where I'm from right so um and it was
just like all guys in the class and I
went up to get mine and like they
started saying like just rude things and
like they just didn't care
my teacher was in the room and they just
didn't care and she would tell them to
stop and they just kept going and then
like they try to whisper it and like I
just heard everything and like I made it
through my present saying what are they
saying
what are something like a [ __ ] and like
laughing and saying that I was gay for
like picking her and just ignorant
things um but I dealt with it in that
class before just um being who I was I
guess um and uh that that date is kind
of like broke me and I like ended up in
the hallway and I was just crying and
the teacher was like yelling like crazy
at the students yeah and did she come
out there and talk to you I mean how did
you what were the next few hours and
then how did you how do you recover from
something like that I don't know she
came out and talked to me um like as
soon as I went out there and then she
went back in and yelled and then she
sent me to the counselor's office I was
in the counselor's office for like an
hour
um none of the kids got in like trouble
well as far as I know but um I don't
know it was just very
I don't think cuz at that point which is
also I guess a crucial part of the story
I was a new student this was eighth
grade and so prior to that and for the
seven years I've been in another school
district and so I was a new kid and um I
just had never been in that situation
before to where people didn't know me or
weren't used to like how I acted or the
things that I liked so it's just
extremely overwhelming and I just had to
cope with it it was a very messy period
of my life my grades dropped in
everything I mean yeah for how how long
was the recovery I mean as a eighth
grader I'd say I hadn't recovered until
I was in high school it was like a huge
like blow to my personality to my just
everything cuz I was just like I was so
careful you when I was younger like I
didn't care about anything I'm just
super nice and like I talked to everyone
and then once I moved and went through
that it was just like whoa not
everyone's hmm you know accepting that
everyone's the same and so um it
eventually came out that I was getting
like bullied I guess when my parents
went to a parent-teacher conference cuz
I hadn't told him anything just cuz I
was that kid and like we moved and I
don't want to like make it seem like
anything was wrong and I was just like
yeah I'm having fun at school but then
they went to conferences and my teachers
were like he's having a rough time and
um they talked to me about it but that
was like near the end of the semester so
you were kind of keeping it to yourself
yeah so in high school you it was kind
of an upswing of okay I'm moving on from
from this this valley this low point
right high school I think was just it
was a good time because it became a
point where you can kind of figure out
who's also interested in what you're
interested in
there are a lot more activities to join
and there was just so many more people
from like all the middle schools in the
district and it was just so much more
diverse and so it was nice to I felt
like I was starting over like I met new
people that didn't go to my middle
school it was just it was a refreshing
start you said in a recent video if you
had to do high school over that how did
you put it I thought that I would come
out of the closet immediately
and just be open for business with my
exact Club but you're laughing it she's
I mean is that it's the truth I would I
always think of like doing things over
and I know people say oh I wouldn't
change a thing
but I would definitely change some
things because I already have this life
I would like to see how it would be
different moving on to college you you
mentioned it seems like college kind of
was like a a wild time you go off to
University of Missouri yes so you you
had to
I mean you ended up doing pretty well in
high school it sounds like in order to
and did you get scholarship there's I
got like a $2,500 okay so you got a
partial scholarship - not the one I want
Mizzou yeah and did you go to school
with some people that you already knew
some yes friends I actually went to
school with my best friend from high
school and then there was just like a
circle of people that you knew from high
school that were going yet you had like
the Oh we'll keep in touch table to each
other that we did that and um it was
just so cool like my parents like I said
I had been super super sheltered and so
I prior to like I hadn't been one of
those kids that like partied in high
school or drink or anything I never had
alcohol before and I'm we got there the
first week and they had a frat party I'm
like the first day after classes and we
went there and like I don't know how I
was like standing up this was literally
the first time I ever drank alcohol but
I was a pro and I just I think in my
head I just accepted the role of like
big brother because it was me and then
like three girls and um we just got to a
point where they were completely wasted
and it was just time to go when I'm
trying to get us to a cab and I was
holding her like under her boobs because
that's as much I'm a skinny guy I was
just trying to like get her there
without like dropping on the floor and
she just peed she just completely peed
it like while I was holding her as
though I wasn't there and I was like
okay cool
you're welcome and I was just so annoyed
well it's actually warm to start and
then it becomes cool huh thanks for the
reminder
rhythmic flashback but I did actually
drop her at that point yeah oh yeah that
was the it's the wall and that was the
define
moment of college free yeah that's when
I was like okay this is real I'm here
and it's about to be a mess and it
became a mess from there in what way it
just you know I I just felt so free like
nothing against my parents but I just it
was awesome to like be in a place where
you go to class you do your homework
when you want you turn it in you have
like freedom you can go eat what you
want go back to your room when you want
and I just is that when you started
making videos on YouTube I started like
a month before I left
oh okay um I was working I got working
my ass off and I just hey what was your
job I was working at Fazoli's which was
like a fast food Italian fast what I'm
telling you know garlic sticks yes it's
so good so good I was doing that and
then I was a waiter at TGI Fridays and I
also did room service there because we
were attached to a Crowne Plaza so I
just made hella tips and I was saving it
off for school is that where you have
Flair the the pins is that TGI Fridays
or just Ruby Tuesday's well it's Fridays
no s yeah it so you have the pin depends
right what kind of pens the old pins
like on yours likes bondage buttons and
suspenders is that no we're nothing is
we have button red shirts with like
checkered there's a place where you they
call it flare like you're like and
however many buttons the waiter has
attached to their suspenders is how much
Flair they had that's not TGI Fridays
like I thought it was I know we did have
a reward with a cauliflower there's a
similar rescue my bean and I'm sure that
people listening know what I'm talking
about but I can't remember that anyway
you have suspenders on no I didn't but
it was awesome and and that's the show
the Jonas Brothers vlog you were
vlogging from the perspective of an
employee at Applebee's
it was TGI Fridays I was cheating oh but
um which is better which is better which
has better food right is no doubt okay
although Applebee's appetizers their
chest
amazing but their entre is Friday's
question okay everybody's got a right to
their own opinion
yes so when you posted that first rant
video when you were cheating on your job
at Applebee's yeah it was because you
had been watching Shane Dawson you're
okay if I'm angry about this this can be
the way for me to get it out
or was it were there other motives too
like I also want to be a youtuber and
I'm gonna try it right now no it was
literally just I was what the whole like
motive I guess was after I saw Shane I
like found vlogger threw him left on
this Gaikwad year I found Chris Crocker
like I just found a whole bunch of
people and like I was fascinated by the
aspect of connecting with people um one
of the first things I started doing was
doing reality show recaps mm-hmm just to
see other people who had similar
interests and like conversate with them
like I was always in the comments just
talking and seeing who had similar
thoughts so that was like my main
motivation and then when this happened
um I did it literally just like get it
out just to like we have a story to tell
um I didn't know anything about being a
youtuber I didn't know what being
youtuber was but did you know that you
were funny because you know there's a
lot of vloggers out there there's a lot
of people who just share the details of
their life and I know there's a lot of
people who are really interested in that
that's not the kind of content that I
consume but with you you're once you get
going it's like a stand-up comedian as
far as I'm concerned right you know I'm
saying it's like you you've got comedic
timing you the way you phrase things
it's really funny and is that the kind
of thing that you're like I know why
people are going to like this or did
your friends know but yo yeah Kingsley
he's funny
it's in people at school told me I was
funny it was not a situation where I
thought I was funny and I didn't like
start uploading because I thought I was
funny I uploaded just to be able to talk
to people um they told me I was funny
and that felt good but I never like even
to this day like I don't
I don't I don't watch myself but clearly
I don't think anyone but yourself yeah I
headed it and then I watch it that one
time to make sure there's no errors and
I upload it and I'm done
like I hate hearing myself talk I'm
actually like and all that some people
have done it for five years how I said
that but I mean but when you edit it I
mean you're sir when I watch it it's at
least every third cut is it's gonna be
on a joke I mean it's gonna be on what's
he gonna say next and in the cut you
know what I mean you're at this point
you're very much it's down to a science
here you know where you're gonna where
you were you're gonna you're gonna get
your questions you're gonna get your
content or your inspiration from and
then you're gonna format it - I'm just
gonna I assume it's not scripted it's
more no like this maybe it's just an
outline in your head it's like mice mice
gets the scripted but the rants and the
vlogs I just I talk I may have a post-it
note to remind me of topics if I've got
more than one but usually I just do want
a video and so I just let it go like
stream-of-consciousness yeah and then
when you edit it you're kind of going
out on joke or out on I mean for me it's
I I'm waiting for you to say it in the
way that only you can say it and then
you're out and then it's not and then
it's another one and it's so how much
are you cutting out I would say I cut
out I think on average I record like
eight to ten minutes and then my videos
like four minutes long so what 60%
effect the math so I cut out that much
that's that's a lot of natural funny if
you can just bang it out and yeah I feel
like I've learned my audience at this
point and like I know what kind of
phrases they like I know what kind of
commentary they want to hear and I just
never want to like ramble for too long
and um that's what I delete a lot is if
I like um like piling on on a certain
topic I'm like oh you said this already
that doesn't need to be said toys so if
it takes you 10 minutes to make the
video and it and you edit it down to
four minutes what do you do with your
free time
Wow
have a podcast and what and I had I
asked I asked that question like a fan
who when they hear that somebody's a
youtuber they assume that what do you
mean you'd be bored for 10 minutes at 10
minutes a week I know that's not the
case it's a mess but you know you you do
have a lot of things going on so I mean
okay you you you fast forwarding from
from college you moved well tell us how
you got out here then we can kind of
talk about what what you do not sure I
didn't get out here actually it was a
very like random I had no plans like
I've always wanted to move to LA not
because of YouTube like even before that
just for a different experience than the
Midwest I wanted to go somewhere that
was like more diverse and open and had a
lot more people and opportunities and um
I had been dating this guy well okay
like my video
I started at school in August of 2009
and then my video that was on Tosh went
viral April 2010 um so the end of my
freshman year was kind of like weird I
was working at Subway I'd worked like
four jobs your sandwich artist yes I was
a sandwich artist I was working at
Subway or worked at a movie theater
I worked Toys R Us for seasonal um and I
thought I was silly you did Toys R Us
over Christmas yeah I worked there from
wow that's a Black Friday
oh really it was a disaster okay tell us
about that I felt like I wanted to quit
but I couldn't it was just ridiculous I
had went home for Thanksgiving break and
then I had to cuz my school is only like
90 minutes from where I grew up and um I
we got there like 5:00 in the morning
and I was just like oh I doesn't look
too busy yet because my doors open at
6:00 or something and as soon it's like
they opened I was just completely I
didn't know what was going on
mothers were like constantly asking
questions kids were running around and I
was there from open to closed it's my
first day I know it was horrific it's
traumatizing soutache kind of wreck he
rescued you from that
yeah it's so weird did he make fun of
you in a show he cuz he can be really
harsh he was not as hard as I've seen
him be his bed at like the worst thing
he said um because one of the things I
said was like I hate being on
chatroulette and all I see is penis and
he like rift like oh I'm sure he's not
so upset about seeing penis or something
like that it was all good so it was
funny I laugh and then from from that
viral video you were you know I got to
do more of this like what was the game
plan actually I was like kind of in
shock like I didn't after I did that
video I did like three more and then I
stopped for a bit um it was just weird
like after it happened after Spring
Break like I went back to work and like
people were coming in and just like
knowing who I was and they were asking
me to like say lines from the video and
stuff and I'm just like whoa there's
this freaking awkward would you say the
lines no I was working I was like no no
no like I'd play I wasn't rude or
anything I just like laugh at all and um
I was like glad when school ended that
year cuz I did I didn't know what the
hell was going on but you started you
took a little break but then you're you
kind of doubled down on it I did because
it was summer and like no offense from
Missouri but I just I was so bored I had
absolutely nothing to do and making
videos like it was fun and um it's not
like there wasn't like that video went
viral but I still didn't have like a lot
of subscribers or like I was getting
more but at that point it wasn't
something I looked at or than you knew
like I still didn't understand what
YouTube was but not really making money
much money yeah yeah so it was just all
weird I was still doing it for fun so
then would it when did it switch to oh I
can I can make enough money here to
decide to move to LA or you know the
honest truth of course I didn't like
start taking YouTube serious look like I
said business until I classed year oh
yeah like even beyond me moving out here
I moved out here because of it um so -
okay well then tell me how you decided
to move out if it wasn't a financial
decision it was a love
and what I really love more like a drama
I went to a Britney Spears concert in
Michigan there she is again I know just
every point of my life uh and the guy I
was with we've been dating for like two
months and then he was like he was
texting this other guy just like
inappropriate things I won't go into
detail but essentially I like broke up
with him and made him fly back to
Missouri and then my friend Stephanie
went to the concert with me instead and
my friend Caitlin who I went to school
with at Mizzou was moving out to LA two
weeks from then and she's been looking
for a roommate and like um I was about
to start my junior year and it was just
like a point in life where I'd like I
didn't care about school um like I
wanted to finish school one day but at
that point I just felt like I was like
getting into debt like I wasn't
motivated I wasn't learning anything new
um I had the thing with the guy and so
it was just like this weird awkward
place of just like I need a change and
like literally when I left Michigan I
called my mom in the car because I had
like a eight hour drive and I told her
like I want to move to LA like Caitlin
needs a roommate she's my friend I have
enough money saved which I did like I
didn't have like a lot but I mean that
was from your all the jobs that she
worked plus a little little YouTube
money I did a little bit Adsense okay so
you had already activated your your ads
and all that yes and so I don't know if
just the end of summer I was like in
kind of a low place and I saw an
opportunity to go somewhere different
and new where I had opportunities where
I had at this point in time like I
didn't know when again I would have the
money to do it I didn't know when I'd
have a roommate when I'd have a ride
like I just felt like it was one of
those opportunities like if I didn't
take it then I would have never ever
been here um and so I did that and then
Here I am and when was that how long ago
was that this was Sept I guess September
2011 okay I moved out here September
13th of 2011 okay
and what was it like I mean when you
when you got out here was it had you
ever been to LA before I had not I
didn't even like I it was completely
just dreams and like a ideal I guess
scenario ahead in my head of what it was
that I just thought that I could ever
move here without ever having had
visited and I was like I was overwhelmed
at first we lived in Redondo Beach
which people they don't live here it's
kind of more suburban not as busy um my
roommate was doing like beach volleyball
so we moved there more so for her it was
just like aw like professionally yeah
she actually went which was another
thing she left me like the rear for
months and I was living here to go play
in Croatia for like five months I was
like you [ __ ] I was so mad but um it
was great the first few months um it was
nice just being in a new environment it
was nice to go to West Hollywood and see
like an abundance of gay people like
just in the streets and like no one
judging them or it was just a completely
different city and life that I had ever
experienced before and what did you
begin to do in terms of YouTube how did
moving out here did it pick up or change
things for that it didn't I um was way
more motivated just because I feel like
um I wasn't in school I had a lot of
time I was trying to get a job at
Blockbuster I remember when I got here
but like months after like they all
closed yeah that was like I guess I
missed that you were about to have every
like every I don't know what the word is
but you you've been a waiter yeah you
know you've worked at Toys R Us
and he wanted to get the video store
credit so you could have like all those
titles my dream job forever I always
dream to work in a video store I loved
that but um mr. be wrong time you know I
know I'm sad but I just was yeah I was
going like really hard on YouTube I had
I made this little backdrop I thought I
was so cool I had like this collage of
like celebrities behind me if when I
talk about pop culture and it was just
like it was a great I felt like
reenergized and then I signed with an
agency like that first summer and um I
worked with like Scooter Braun like I
just when I moved back here I just was
completely just like oh my god like this
is awesome this what I wanted mm-hmm
scooter he's uh who it he managed he
manages Justin Bieber that's right
wanted ariana grande well I mean in and
since since coming out here I mean over
the these past three or so years I mean
the momentum has only continued to grow
for you you've been one of those voices
on YouTube that kind of gets this
initial wave of momentum and then
maintains it which is not an easy thing
to do
and now you announce at the end of 2013
that oh and you know it's into 2014 I'm
done with YouTube so what's up with that
that's like I had an asterisk to that
I'm done haha okay blogging oh okay yeah
I not leaving YouTube no I'm still doing
like skits and more premium and quote
programming but I just won't be vlogging
anymore okay what's the what's the
rationale and is there a risk associated
with that there's definitely risk um
the rationale first like I just it's
gotten to a point for me where it's just
hard to like continuously discuss things
by myself like I can't just be in a room
conversating to the camera there's only
so many different things I could say so
many comments I can make
and when I got the opportunity to do my
podcast that's why I kind of jumped on
it because I loved the idea of having a
co-host and having guests and like this
team of people that you like working off
of and um that's something that I've
desired because like I said it's just
gotten hard for me to talk constantly by
myself and um I started doing skits well
I didn't like on and off when I was in
college but I got into it
at the beginning of last year and um
everyone responded well to it so I was
just like this is what I'd enjoy doing
because I went school for journalism and
we had to take like all these writing
courses and I did creative writing
I've always enjoyed writing like even
elementary school I wrote these books
that are still like at my house I wrote
these like murder mysteries I have like
seven of them and they're each like 60
pages but I just always liked being
creative and so when I saw the
opportunity to like switch over from
just me talking to like writing skits
and like writing content and I talked to
people like Giorgio Safa who did like
storytellers and I just see all these
like other aspects of things that like
inspire me and make me like excited to
do a video or to create content that's
what I want to do I don't want to be in
a situation where I'm just like oh I'm
talking just because this is what you
guys like because I feel like there's a
point where they can realize you're not
really into it anymore yeah
you know I don't want that to happen but
you gave him over a year notice that's
dead-white a quite an advanced notice to
know like I didn't want to be like
dramatic about it like I didn't want to
have it be December and be like well
that was my last vlog and everyone's
like whoa whoa whoa what so I'm sure
even even though you gave the your
notice I'm sure you got a lot of upset
fans I mean that's just what happens
right yeah um it might be a brilliant
marketing scheme I mean how many last
albums does jay-z have you know this is
it and this is it and this is it well
did you have any of those be smart those
dramatic messages people said you don't
understand I mean your vlogs or what get
me up I still get tweets like every day
at least one how does that make you feel
um
it makes me feel like good that they
have enjoyed it so much but then it also
makes me like scared to like do
something new because I'm like worried
about how they're gonna respond to it
but I feel like every time I've tried
something new on my channel there's been
the thing that I like about YouTube is
that people can be honest and like you
can tell if your audience likes what
you're putting up or if they don't and
um
at this point I'm just at a point where
it's like okay they're either gonna like
it or they're not
I'll keep what they like and then what
they don't I'll scrap and so it's just
all like anxious anxious okay are you
developing more of a detailed plan of
what next year will look like already I
mean is it because when you talk about
skits
you mean scripted content where you're
playing multiple characters it's still
gonna kind of a vlog format right well
what you've been doing what you've done
yeah but this will be more like
webseries ish okay um I've written a
bunch like I've written like two seasons
of one thing and like we're still
planning everything else right now so
it's like murder mystery yeah I wish but
uh maybe one day but we have like five
things for like fleshing out and like
over the next few months I'll be like
filming stuff and editing it and like
just having everything ready to go by
January hmm yeah so it's just it's
really nerve-wracking but hopefully it's
planned really well what's it I mean can
you tell us a name of the series no I
can't can you tell us one word of the
name of the series Internet okay
Internet is one of the word internet in
it it does there's another one Kingsley
yeah Internet overload Kings actually if
you think about it I think you can get
the rest of it but I'm not gonna confirm
or deny how many words - it's okay in
one of them's Internet would you rather
win the title the greatest gay youtuber
or the greatest black youtuber I think
I'd probably say great it's black why
just because it's more distinctive and I
feel like I stand out more okay
you know you have Tyler and Troy in like
50,000 other people it both like so I
would just like to own my blackness so
there's more gay youtubers than black
youtubers I felt like that so you wanna
I just wanna like honestly
both these titles are mess but I think
that I just feel like if I said greatest
gay there will be alive because that's
clearly Tyler Oakley Tyler Oakley is the
best that ever was and so I just would
feel wrong claiming that title when I
know damn well that isn't true oh but
you you can take the title of the best
black guys I will I will wrestle DeStorm
until I snatch the crown well you should
you should probably charge pay-per-view
or something for that now to explain bad
knee by the way Andy well I think it's
better now I think it's better now it's
probably still a lot of rehab he's
probably still weakened and yeah every
time I see his Instagram he's brought up
a mountain or something like that so I
think he's doing fine but this leads to
another question which is what link was
kind of you know exploring was this this
aspect of people categorize people and
on YouTube any any form of entertainment
is it's done that that much more but
then when you're trying to kind of break
through in a medium like YouTube where
it's not about who's promoting you it's
not about what network you signed with
and so much of the success of a youtuber
is just based on the youtuber right it's
just based on the content that they
create and how they connect with an
audience and anytime you have a
distinctive it can be an edge in a lot
of ways right yes so you've got the you
got a distinctive of being gay you've
got a distinctive of being black and
those put you in a minority winning time
when it comes to just overall YouTube
but you probably weren't thinking any of
these things when you got involved
you're just like I'm gonna rant about
this when did it kind of hit you that
you were like oh I am sort of
potentially the best black youtuber like
when did you start thinking in those
categories that people were probably
already categorizing you in I think the
first time was when I discovered tumblr
um there were like Geoff's or gay do you
guys or guess we say we say jokes around
here gives to guess that jag F of myself
I would see people like
who's the bunny black guy and I was like
oh they talking about me and now there
was the first time I saw myself like
labeled and then when I was with a
network and we were just looking at
stats and I just saw like the lack of
color
I'm like the top 100 200 list and I was
like oh wow this is very interesting um
like race and sexuality it's just
something I think about a lot so I guess
was kind of an eye-opener and I saw it
as something that could work to my
advantage
um if it needs to but I just never ever
think about it but when you I mean you
kind of alluded to earlier in the
conversation of there being a king's
like character I mean our conversation
has been this kind of you know it's been
kind of I wouldn't it's been laid-back
but it's not the on-camera persona so
I'm glad you're giving us the real you
which kind of clarifies is it just amped
up is it a character and is there a
temptation to be because this these are
your labels to be gayer to be blacker I
definitely there there is um one of the
things I talked about when I did my drum
out life it's just what I went through
in eighth grade how it kind of became
like subdued and more conscious of what
I was saying and how I was acting when I
make my videos I kind of keep in the
back of my head there like I didn't have
YouTube growing up and right now I feel
like a lot of kids do and some of them
from like the things they write I know
they see people like me and Tyler and
whoever they're watching and they just
feel inspired because of the way we are
and for me my whole demeanor of like not
caring and being strong and outgoing
that's just something I want to project
so that if like a gay kid is watching me
and they do behave that way they can see
that it's okay so it's definitely like
intentional and on purpose
but it at the same time like it's Who I
am but it's just such a huge
magnification of that like how you said
I'm not like that
the time but I think for the sake of
entertainment and for making these
people laugh and just trying to make
them happy I can do that for like you
know four minutes every other day or ten
minutes and then edit it down yes 60
percent out well we wish you the best
man we we've enjoyed getting to know you
and thanks for coming in sign the table
[Music]
and there you have it our ear biscuit
with king so hey Kingsley right and I
think we got King not necessarily
Kingsley and not the character the real
person yeah meaning that he was just
very much in an introspective mood I
think that was one of the interesting
things is I think when you watch his
videos sometimes he gets really worked
up and you might have to cut your your
headphone volume down a little bit but I
almost felt like I wanted to turn him up
because he's a very mild-mannered guy in
person I think a lot of people might be
surprised by that but I think we
captured that and that's what you get
with an ear biscuit you get the the
flipside at times you get the the real
side so and that that's what I I'm
continually excited about this show that
we can do that there's no pressure to
perform but it does raise a question
link are you in character right now or
like right now right now are you being
the real Lang have you been in character
our entire lives that's funny I mean I
just wondering because we do a lot of
entertaining together we're always
talking to each other but also talking
to an audience well yeah I mean when
we're in the conversation with somebody
it's very I I think you know you
listening can tell that we're just
asking a legitimate questions but right
now there's an amped-up kind of a little
characterization I mean on good mythical
morning
are we being ourselves there are we in
character we're we're in a character
that is a heightened version of
ourselves and and even right now I'm not
I'm not giving you the heightened
linked the character but I'm not giving
you link the the left just woke up the
link that is just there's no mic in
front of my face and there's not an
audience listening I'm talking to you
listener and I'm talking to you Rhett
you are you next right right yeah and
it's because my voice when I when I'm
not in character it's still this silky
smooth my voice is like this it's kind
of mopey it's I the natural me wants to
speak like this very low and like a
robot the kind of voice that would talk
you through something if an instruction
manual were to like a really bad audio
book please like a really technical
audio book thank you for purchasing
about like certain intro to circuits the
heartbeat I know it would be like thank
you for purchasing the happy Jax jungle
gym guaranteed to provide years of fun
for you and your family there's like an
audio track for the happy jacket jungle
gym if there was like what to put it
together like a new audio instruction
assembly make sure you have the
following tools rubber mallet
screwdriver that's pretty much all you
need everything else in the kit that
things I want to speak I lay out
everything from the kit and make sure
you have it all I know you're not
actually going to do that but the people
and customer service require that I tell
you to lay out everything this is a
great idea not just because it's how I
really speak but because if I had an
audio instructional manual I would know
how long I was supposed to be taking to
do things when I look at the the like
the total runtime of the audio is that
what you knew yeah yeah it's like now
you should have gotten like the first
rung on now you should have the first
rung on so you don't have to pause the
audio instruction it is real tangent so
I'll wait it would be timed so that you
were doing it at normal speed because
we're not building something I want you
I'm doing compared to other men out
there in the world that's how I feel
sometimes if you are not done your
progress as it corresponds to the
average man is below average you
you are a below-average man so it's kind
of a demotivational thing - mm-hmm huh I
think this may be our future audio
instructionally instructions
downloadable only from our website which
of course is rhett and Link duck that's
right oh we turned this into a promotion
we should probably turn this back into a
promotion for Kingsley I think Stu
Kingsley for being on the the ear
biscuits and giving us a real biscuit to
sink our ears into if you want to let
Kingsley know how much you appreciate
him being on ear biscuits please do you
can tweet at him that's at Kingsley
there's three wise at the end though
that's he's got that one that was his
Kings Kingsley with two extra wise three
total wise all at the end so let him
know hashtag ear biscuits on that also
give us feedback that way and as we
always say leave a review on iTunes
leave a comment on SoundCloud these
things are valuable to us in many ways
emotionally mostly yeah if they're
positive
okay well we'll be back next week with
another beaut count on it
[Music]
[Music]